le 20 janvier 2016 la disparition
inquiétante de jacky denjean chef
d'entreprise de 57 ans est signalée par
son épouse à son domicile des objets
cassés plusieurs traces de sang sont
retrouvées une dizaine de jours plus
tard
un premier suspect est interpellé bruno
télamon le 19 janvier il se serait rendu
au domicile de la victime pour
s'acquitter d'une importante dette
d'argent de l'ordre de plusieurs
milliers d'euros et dans le montant
précis reste à déterminer
pendant l' enquête le principal accusé
va changé de nombreuses fois de version
mettre en cause trois autres personnes
qu'il ne connaissait pas mais qui selon
lui auraient été présentes ce soir là
chez jacky donjon jusqu'à finalement
accusé l'un de ses amis william palcy
présent lui aussi dans le box des
accusés
l' enquête déterminera qu'ils étaient
effectivement présents au moment des
faits mais l'homme de 35 ans comparaîtra
libre tout comme le troisième suspect
kevin jacques andré coquin
c'est grâce aux déclarations de ce
dernier que le corps du chef
d'entreprise avait été découvert cinq
mois plus tard en juin 2016 dans une
ravine à fond saint denis c'est deux
suspects sont poursuivis pour non
dénonciation de crimes et recels de
cadavres
il encourt jusqu'à trois ans de prison
bruno tellemment lui risque la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité il est accusé de
vol avec violence ayant entraîné la mort
ce matin une large partie de l'audience
a été consacrée à la personnalité des
accusés
des jeunes hommes plutôt favorisé dira
la présidente jusque là sans histoire
pour deux d'entre eux william palcy et
kevin jacques andré coquin winhôtel à
moi pour sa part été condamné pour vols
il y à 13 ans les auditions de témoins
et d'experts vont se poursuivre demain